mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
start with a square inscribe a circle
in this square and shade the region
between the circle
and the square in blue for the next step
inscribe a square inside of this circle
and again
inscribe a circle inside of this square
once again in this step shade the region
between the circle
and the square in blue now repeat this
process
indefinitely the question
is if we repeat this infinitely many
times
if the first square has a side length
equal to 1
what is the total sum of all the areas
that are shaded in blue pause the video
if you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
we will first go over the sum of a
geometric series and then we will solve
the problem
let's get started with the sum of the
geometric series
suppose we have a geometric series where
the first term is equal to a
and we have a common ratio equal to r
let's first consider the finite sum
where the final term
is a multiplied by r to the power of k
let's find a formula for this sum
we will first consider a copy of this
sum
now let's multiply each term in this sum
by
the constant r let's distribute this
through to each term
now let's line up the powers of r
furthermore just to make this a little
bit easier to see
let's make the term a multiplied by r to
the power of three
let's just group that and then let's
pull
out a multiplied by r to the power of k
let's now subtract the second equation
from the first
the result on the left hand side will be
s k
minus r multiplied by s k
on the right hand side we have some
interesting cancellations
a r will cancel then ar squared will
cancel
and so on all of these terms in the
middle will cancel this is reminiscent
of a telescope that retracts upon itself
and only the beginning and end survive
for this reason it's called a
telescoping sum
so the result on the right hand side
will be equal to the first term
a minus the last term a multiplied by r
to the power of k plus 1.
we can further simplify this let's
factor out
s k and then we will divide both sides
of this equation
by 1 minus r this
is the formula for the sum of a
geometric series up to a finite term
what if we wanted an infinite geometric
series well let's suppose the common
ratio
has an absolute value that's less than
one
in this case the limit as k goes to
infinity
of the absolute value of r to the power
of k plus one will be equal to zero
so we take the limit as k goes to
infinity of this sum
we'll take the limit as k goes to
infinity of the formula for the sum
now we know that this term will go to
zero
so it will vanish thus we are left that
the limit
is equal to a divided by 1 minus r
it's equal to the first term divided by
1 minus the common ratio
so let's use this formula to solve the
problem
let's get a little bit of notation let's
suppose the first area will be equal to
b1
the second area will be equal to b2 and
so on
let's calculate b1 the side of the
square is equal to 1
which means the diameter of the circle
is equal to 1.
thus the radius of the circle is equal
to 0.5
we can thus calculate b1 and it will be
equal to the area of the square
minus the area of the circle so it'll be
equal to 1 squared
which is equal to 1 minus pi multiplied
by 0.5
squared this simplifies to be 1
minus pi over four now
let's calculate the next area
the diameter of this circle is equal to
one
when we inscribe a square into it
then its diagonal will exactly be
a diameter of the previous circle
so the diagonal of this square is equal
to one
we can then calculate the side length of
the square because we have a 45-45-90
right triangle
so if the hypotenuse of the square is
equal to one
one of the legs will be equal to one
divided by the square root of two
from here we know that the side of the
square is one divided by the square root
of 2
which means the diameter of this circle
is equal to 1
divided by the square root of 2 which
means the radius is exactly half of that
so we can calculate b2 it'll be equal to
the area the square
minus the area of the circle we do some
simplification
and we get that b2 is equal to one half
minus pi
over eight from here
let's compare b1 and b2
notice the b2 is exactly equal to half
of b1
so b2 over b1 is equal to one half
by very similar calculation we can show
that each subsequent blue area is
exactly one half of the previous blue
area in other words b k plus one
divided by b k is equal to one half
so we have a common ratio of one half
between the areas
let's now get to an answer
we want to calculate the infinite sum b1
plus b2
plus b3 and so on the first term
will be equal to b1 and the common ratio
will be equal to one-half so we can use
the formula for the sum of the geometric
series
and it'll be equal to a divided by one
minus the common ratio
a is equal to b1 and the common ratio is
equal to one-half
so we'll do some simplification here
this will be equal to b
one divided by one half which will be
equal to two times b1
then we know that b1 is equal to one
minus pi over four
so this will be equal to two minus pi
over two
and that's the answer the sum of all of
these blue areas
is equal to two minus pi over two
what a beautiful answer thanks for
making us one of the best communities on
youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time
[Music]
you